you're lucky then
who'da said your purpose in life is to
find your purpose sure that make sense
what's your purpose
protect us from all oppression
on sacrifice shall allow the undying
okay then
remember to have fun along the way
alright man where'd you train come on
which is where you can't really get
there from here
nice try now it's time to go well if you
really need to leave this is just a
practice sword it doesn't even have an
edge trust me you don't want to know
what it feels like to have a practice
sword to make you hard on the side of
the case I already do ask master make
Goomba thunder I'm asking you nicely one
last time please go I apologize for any
inconvenience I had to try try what to
survive I stepped out for the the snows
would be the wind I kept on falling
something I looked up and these two men
standing above me so dark and Kashi and
they were they monks
ordered the crane mother Wow
monks the order of the crane mother what
kind of monks are those the warrior
monks
[Applause]
[Music]
you
see youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Easter Egg video for the first
couple of episodes so here we go so many
comic book shoutouts so if you're new to
the channel I do all kinds of Marvel
videos there's going to be a bunch of
Iron Fist happening be sure to subscribe
to get everything
there's even a Marvel giveaway that's
going on right now so let's talk was the
biggest stuff first so he explains shall
allow the Dragon tongue lung the capital
cities of heaven in how he's a mortal
enemy of the hand so I'll explain some
of the comic book changes as I work
through this Easter Egg video but
there's a whole bunch of stuff the order
of the crane mother so we get all this
drops in the first couple of episodes
just helping you place him in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because if you've
read his backstory a lot of you guys
said that you've read the immortal iron
fist again recently which is a great map
for action run but you just don't know
what the TV show is going to do and how
it's going to treat the character so you
actually see some of these episodes but
just working our way down the list the
big one shall loud the dragon so if you
don't know that is that's where he gets
his iron fist power from he defeats the
dragon the dragon gets reborn another
iron fist comes along defeats the dragon
gets their iron fist power but the way
they transfer that power is they plunge
their fists into the heart of the Dragon
after it's been defeated when he calls
it shall Lao the undying it's because
once you defeat the dragon its reborn as
an egg it hatches again when it's time
for another iron fist to take the power
he says he's tasked with defending
Kunlun against any interlopers anyone
that would seek them harm he's only the
defender of the city when the dragon is
around so if there's no iron fist the
dragon itself protects Kunlun they've
only touched on the seven capital cities
of heaven in the first couple of
episodes but each city has its own
immortal weapon that defends it the same
way that iron fist takes shall Laos
power and defense that city but what
about the title sequence there's a big
easter egg during that so that's
basically showing you him harnessing his
sheep but it's one of my favorite title
sequences of all the shows they're all
fantastic all the Netflix shows have the
best title sequences but daredevil an
iron fist now are my favorites the way
it builds towards the climax here this
is what it looks like when he's going
full-blown iron fist
[Music]
the title of the first episode snow
gives way is a reference to Kunlun
sinking with the earth is once every 15
years on the TV show in the comics it's
once every 10 years every 88 years the
celestial clock that's formed by the
seven capital cities of heaven syncs up
they all form this special island where
they all duel each other and they get to
decide the order of the celestial clock
so what happens is if you lose the
tournament or you do really poorly then
your capital city of heaven will get
locked away from the earth for an even
longer period of time it determines the
order but if you're wondering why the
outcasts song is playing on his iPod
when he rolls up like a hobo with no
shoes on it's because that was what he
had on him when the plane crashed that's
how long he's been gone so that lets you
know that he crashed in about the year
2000 just assuming that that song was
brand-new when the plane crash so while
he has defeated the dragon Shou Lao he
hasn't been on the street being the Iron
Fist quite as long as daredevil has been
daredevil the really cool Easter egg is
he's entering the building here he's
looking at the highlight reel seeing all
the different things that Rand has it's
business and you see those pills they're
probably caught up with the IgH company
they're like a billion dollar
corporation multi-billion dollar
corporation so they have their you know
wait for it Big Pun hand in a bunch of
things so the hand is a big part of this
series it all explained as I go through
my easter egg but you see those pills so
pharmacology is a really big deal in
this series it's a really insidious way
that people get medicated they kind of
treat illness in a really specific way
like when he's in the psychiatric
hospital everyone's like oh you know I
was fine and then they put me on all
these pills and said that I was bipolar
that implies they're tied up with the
IgH company that made those special
pills that also gave the purple man his
powers so it's all connected it will
come back around during defenders there
were a number of big plot lines that
they set up the hand is one of those the
drug business is another there were
actually a couple times like even Ward
Meechum was medicating himself they
really want you to think about big
corporations pushing drugs on people but
you meet joy and Ward Meechum the change
from the comics here is that Ward
Meacham is actually the brother of
Harold Meacham Harold Meacham is sort of
like the
kingpin of this series like you see him
fighting like in the way the Iron Fist
is meant to be this really great martial
artist that's been teeing up a fight
between the two of them later on but he
is technically not the worst villain on
the show because he gets really excited
when he finds out that Iron Fist is the
mortal enemy of the hand then he finds
the handprint where did you go when he
comes back to his apartment like even
though he's a billionaire seemingly has
all this power is a prisoner of the hand
himself and it seems like he had to fake
his death because of something that he's
involved in with them we meet colleen
wings straight out of the comics
daughter to the dragon badass martial
artist the only real big change from the
comics is that she doesn't know about
Danny ran before he comes in the comics
her father's a professor he knows all
about the iron fist when he senses that
he is coming from Kunlun he sends
Colleen to help him out directly so
really there was no get-to-know-you
period she just shows up and says though
you're the iron fist let's go fight some
evil but speaking of which the dojo he
actually gave the shadow to Lake hung
the Thunder he's the person that trained
the iron fist in like when he's talking
about crane mother so the series might
be treating her in a slightly different
way but I think that Madame Gao is
supposed to be the crane mother of this
series but technically in the comics
she's the leader of one of the other
immortal cities when he wakes up in the
hospital the doctor says he's Donald
birch that's actually a character that
Power Man and Iron Fist fought in the
comics Danny tells the doctors that his
art teacher was mr. Miller Frank Miller
did the Power Man and Iron Fist comic
book back in the day so that's just a
nice week at that it was even a Spider
Man Easter Egg when the doctor calls him
John Anderson that was actually a
character who fought with spider-man to
defeat Doctor Octopus so we got all this
spider-man MCU stuff happening I'm just
waiting for the day when the de-facto
newspaper and news organization of the
MCU becomes the Daily Bugle that would
be so amazing but the way they end the
first couple of episodes is just by
teeing up the hand as this really
ominous things is going to continue
through the rest of the season
he says he's their mortal enemy so think
of the way they were big for daredevil
season two they're going to be even
bigger for Iron Fist and they might even
tease some Elektra stuff because they
had just started to resurrect her at the
end of that series and we finally get to
see him
use the iron fist so he says pain helps
them focus is Chi focusing is Chi allows
him to harness the abilities of the iron
fist
so they didn't really address it but one
of his powers as the iron fist is the
ability to use his Chi to heal himself
but if you spotted any other Easter eggs
that I didn't mention just write them
below in the comments and what I'll do
is I'll do a video like this for every
couple of episode so like episode 3 4 5
in the next couple days and so on and so
forth till I finish the season so be
sure to check everything out you don't
have to binge it all at once but if you
want to try totally go for it it's going
to be awesome but what's going to happen
is is I have new spider-man venom that
I'm going to be posting later tonight
they confirmed that they're working on a
spider-man venom movie what you wait for
that you can click here to listen to
Iron Fist talk about defender season 1
they're shooting right now and you can
click here for my non-spoilery review
for the first half of the season thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight